Single letter changes in the genome are referred to
as single nucleotide variations or SNVs. Some of you
may have heard of SNVs before, but maybe under
a different name. Single nucleotide polymorphism or SNPs. SNVs and
SNPs are the same thing. But the convention is
changing, and SNV is a newer abbreviation. It's one we're
adopting in our course because it's technically more accurate.
But for all intents and purposes, it means the same
thing as a SNIP, if you've heard of one before. Now,
SNVs or single nucleotide variations, are one of the most common
forms of mutations in humans, and it represents a lot of
the variation in the human gene pool. When you have an
SNV, the effect it can have depends entirely on whether it's
in the coding region or the non-coding region of your genome.
So I want you to tell me where do you think
a bigger effect would be had for an SNV? The coding
region or the non-coding region? Pick one of them
and then justify your answer in the text box.